it genuinely does feel like history has
found the two of you
and put you in this position uh because
so much does rest on this race
uh and there could not be two better
individuals
to represent the the democratic party
and the hopes and dreams of tens of
millions
tens of millions of americans we need to
invest in america one of the things that
both john and i agree on and we've been
talking about
is a historic investment in
infrastructure
which would include also green
infrastructure
so that we create jobs with a livable
wage for people in the short term
and position the american economy to
compete
in a global world uh in a in
in amidst increasing globalization you
know reverend and i were discussing this
recently and and
how an infrastructure plan can really
unite the people of the state because of
the economic opportunity that it
represents
for communities urban suburban and rural
because
if done right it will mean equitable
access to economic opportunity for
marginalized communities because
it means that those nine rural hospitals
that have closed in ten years
can be replaced and more built it means
clinics can be built in underserved
areas it means
rural broadband which is the rural
electrification of our time
it means environmental remediation where
there's been contamination it means the
kinds of investments in clean energy
that mean we're not only building a
sustainable economy but also one
where georgia is the leading producer of
clean energy in the region
that is an initiative that can unite the
people of this state that can break down
partisan barriers
[Music]
zack it is 2021. 2020
is over ah this we made a year
the year that uh we all wish
we could talk about a race from the
memory banks there were some good things
that happened
i mean joe won uh that that was epic
um that's the main thing that sticks out
to me in a good way
that's a big one donald trump not being
present anymore um
for half the country yeah joe's gonna
get sworn in in just a
couple of weeks thank goodness uh so far
2021
is off to a fine start but we're gonna
know a whole lot more
about how we're gonna feel about 2021
this week january 5th tuesday
the georgia special senate runoffs both
take place
one of the things i'm like uh scratching
my
chin about is are we gonna know the
results
on tuesday night no no way
zero percent chance because you know if
it's close there's going to be a recount
uh you know you especially if the
republicans lose there's going to be
like um you know or you know if
democrats come close like
either side is very much entitled to a
recount
it may be close it may be very close
uh we actually have
uh some parts of a conversation i had
with both jon ossoff and reverend
warnock
a little bit later in this show so just
to be clear to folks this is not like
they didn't sit for a podcast interview
for a very long discourse uh
with with the senate candidates um but i
i did interview them for an event and we
have some uh
parts of that event a little bit later
on uh i did get to know both reverend
warnock and john ossoff over
the last number of weeks and they're
great
they are truly awesome leaders public
servants they would make phenomenal
senators their opponents david perdue
and kelly lefler
are really not great
at all like they're really you know like
there's some republicans i'm just like
yeah yeah you know i kind of like this
person or you know this person really
has something to say
and like that does not really uh
describe david perdue or
kelly lefler so for for those of you who
have not
for those of you listening who have not
followed
this race the politics center political
senate race in georgia for the past
number of months
um which may include me in some ways um
because i'm
politics out it's into in a lot of ways
post
the presidential election can you give
us give us like an overview of what what
the hell's going on
in georgia you mentioned that the people
running um the way we're at and
just catch us all up to speed oh i will
set the stage
sure for those of you who are like zach
sorry man i'm sick of politics these
races are so high stakes
it's unbelievable where right now
the senate is essentially 48 democrat
50 republican and so if democrats win
both of these seats it becomes 50 50 and
then
the vice president kamala harris will be
the tiebreaker
so you go from republican control of the
senate and mitch mcconnell as the
majority leader who gets to decide
what gets voted on and doesn't get voted
on two
chuck schumer the majority leader
demote mitch mcconnell to the minority
and then you have a really different
landscape in terms of
what can happen out of washington and
let's jump
to the biggest example of this which is
cash relief and then we'll come back to
the georgia
georgia race so right now
as we're having this conversation we are
approximately
five senatorial votes shy of
approximately 180 to 200 million
americans getting 2
000 each actually it's higher because i
saw the total
dollar amount it's something because
it's a more expansive definition this
time it's something like 237 million
americans getting 2 000 each there are
literally five human beings
standing uh in the way of that happening
and it's infuriating it boggles my mind
there are times when i think to myself i
can't believe we're this close to this
happening
and then there most of the time i'm like
i can't believe this is not happening
given how close it is and that there are
these five [ __ ] and you can just
pick
any five you know where like
imagine if you had the power to
uh send out two thousand dollars to 237
million
people and you thought no no let's not
do that even though there's a pandemic
even though over 10 million
has been lost even though they're food
lines for miles even though
uh millions of americans are facing
evictions
uh again during a pandemic uh let's not
do that
no um every other country developed
country
yeah the developed countries are doing
the common sense thing which is like hey
stay home and we should send you some
money so you can stay home and and you
know not be freaking out and
not be stressed out yeah and
and not feel like you have to go out and
work to survive i mean there are
essential workers who we are very
grateful
for working but there are a lot of folks
who are somewhere in this
like uh gray area where it's like well i
don't have enough to survive so i guess
i have to go out there and
look for business as my you know as like
uh
let's say uber driver something like
that um
so well yeah retail uh
in some cases non-essential so yeah
uh so we are this close and the dynamic
around cash relief
it is fascinating how it's developed
um so i'm going to rewind for a minute
and listen to the podcast know
about um like the the main cash relief
component
so i won't review that in depth um but
this two thousand dollar uh a month
proposal really got kick-started by
donald trump
in a very very big way uh so it was
floating around
uh the senate and the house it
essentially settled on six hundred
dollars which was previously zero so
there was part of me that was like well
six hundred dollars sucks but
sure is a hell of a lot better than zero
and it's 600
ahead it included dependence so if
you're like a single mom with two kids
you get eighteen hundred dollars so like
it you know it wasn't zero but
um but sure it wasn't as good as two
thousand dollars um so then donald trump
comes out and says this should be two
thousand dollars ahead
um and then the politics of it uh
shuffle now to her great credit um and
chuck schumer's great credit the
democrats then just come out full born
or like heck yes let's do it
like trump says two thousand dollars and
then the house is like yeah let's do it
and they hold an up or down vote on the
two thousand dollars and this also
is a huge credit uh to our
representatives two-thirds of the house
approves the two thousand dollars
uh check in cash release proposal
almost immediately including dozens of
republicans
uh so you get like a real consensus in
the house saying yes to two thousand
dollars
and then it goes to the senate and
here's where it gets wild
is you have a handful of republicans who
come out and say yeah i'm on board with
with the two thousand dollars uh so it
starts with josh hawley
who's been for it the whole time but
then marco rubio comes out and says i am
for it
then lindsey graham comes forward and
says i am for it
then and here's where georgia comes into
play the two
georgia senators who know that their
political career is like
neck and neck on the line um come out
and say
i'm for it too so
so at this point you have five
republican senators
you have virtually all of the democrats
so you're at like 53 or so
um and then to make it filibuster proof
you need to get to 60. and then there
were two other senators that also came
out for it so you're about five votes
away
um and and that's the the picture as it
stands
right now as we're talking mitch
mcconnell then has the most ridiculous
objection ever he's like no
no no two thousand dollar checks because
it would be quote unquote socialism for
the rich
which makes zero sense because the
checks
are to some extent means tested so if
you are really rich you probably don't
get them
um but but then if you look at the 237
million people are going to get them the
vast majority of those people
are not rich at all so really what he's
saying made zero sense
and it's just it's just total nonsense
and [ __ ] and he's the one who
obviously passed and drove through the
tax cuts for the rich
um and the large companies so the social
inflammation that was truly socialism
for the rich
ridiculous and bernie called him out on
it so give bernie sanders
a lot as we i give bernie so much credit
um because he he's been uh championing
the relief checks
uh harder than anyone bernie's been our
voice on this in many ways which has
been cool
because you weren't yeah um for a lot of
reasons you know i mean
we had a call with bernie um a couple
weeks ago
and um yeah he's been our voice on this
for sure
[Music]
it's time for everyone's favorite ad
hello tushy
new rear new you baby in 2021
don't just make a commitment to wash
your hands every time you go to the
bathroom
go the extra mile and use a bidet
which is pretty cool and wash your
underside so the future of toileting has
arrived guys i love
this thing um this sounds weird but
bidets are
way better than uh frankly that the
traditional toilet paper that we've all
been using
um so i've been thrilled with uh using
hello tushy
and um the new brand new
hello toshi 3.0 bidet attachment um
is fantastic and you save money on
toilet paper it
is more uh environmentally friendly it
is cleaner um
i freaking love this thing um so
there's no need to wipe you just use it
wash off and go
and every bidet attachment has a 60-day
risk-free guarantee
and a 12-month warranty so you can try
it risk free which is pretty awesome
because i know people are very sensitive
about how they use the bathroom what
they do in there
this if you try it and you love it you
have a brand new routine if you don't
like it no worries so
here's the deal if you go to
hellotushy.com yang you'll get 10
percent
off plus free shipping so you could try
out the bidet
and get 10 off and get free shipping
it's our special offer for our yang
speaks listeners go to
dot hellotushyushy.com slash yang for 10
off that's hellotushy.com
yang
[Music]
so another example of the shifting
dynamics lindsey graham then comes out
and says
hey we should have a vote on this and i
bet if we have a vote it passes
like he goes against mitch mcconnell
being like look if you put this out in
front of
the the senators like it's really going
to be political suicide
to say no to this thing um and
then here's here's where the plot
thickens even more so bernie sanders
gets up and says
uh we we should not let this defense
authorization bill pass unless we have a
vote on the two thousand dollars
um so the senate's rules are very very
pro-senator
in that essentially any senator can like
filibuster
something and like impede progress um
unless it gets overrun by like you know
near like super majorities essentially
so bernie steps forward and says hey no
vote on the defense
authorization bill without the 2000
checks
the defense authorization bill is
essentially needed to like
fund the military it's very very
foundational like so it was very brave
of bernie
uh and then when the republicans then
said hey screw you bernie let's just
override this thing
and get this show moving the vast
majority
of democrats joined the republicans and
saying let's override bernie
41 of them to be precise there were six
senators in the democratic party who
decided to stay with bernie and say
like yeah let's let's not do this thing
unless we can vote on the two thousand
dollar checks
um so i don't know how you feel about
this zach but a lot of people are pissed
off about it because they're like wait a
minute bernie stood up and did the
spartacus thing and was like you know
i'm going to or the gandalf thing or
whatever your favorite like you know
heroic stuff i guess the tide is
yeah yeah yeah but like they shall not
pass really
uh and and uh and then only
six democrats decided to not vote
against bernie on this
uh and the six senators if i remember
them are
elizabeth warren ed markey jeff merkley
ron wyden um and i'm missing
uh just the far left chris van hollen
uh was was another like and i gotta say
like
when i looked at that list of senators i
was like i now
love those senators because they
actually
are legit for real they were willing to
stand with bernie against this vote to
fund the military to try and fight for
two thousand dollar checks um and it did
pain me that there were not more of them
this one i'll say this it is fun
before you ran for president you
wouldn't have been able to talk about
any of this
like the fact that you know how much
you've learned we've had to learn on how
the senate works and congress works and
who's who's the players are is
fascinating kind of fun
this to me is is um
does it it's more of a question does it
show you just who these guys actually
represent
the fact that bernie's like hey we're
not voting on like the num the
millions of uh billions of dollars we're
gonna spend on these private companies
or
uh there's all these defense budgets
we've um approved
um before we give money to people like
i'm gonna stand for the people and only
six people lined up behind him
does that just is that like a good
healthy indication of where our
what our congress actually represents
right now who they actually are
representing
or that's where my head goes i don't
know what you think on that
you know i think it was a brave
potentially politically unpopular stance
to take
uh i wish more democrats had decided to
side with bernie it's like everyone just
stood up and we're like yeah let's not
do anything until we get this two
thousand dollar up or down vote
if you get that vote in front of the
floor i think you get
another um five republican senators just
to be like what am i gonna do like
stand in the way of my people on two
thousand dollar checks like an idiot
like it's one thing and the dynamic with
the georgia senators
is instructive where they're literally
getting voted on
you know like right now or you know
tomorrow um and they were like well i
certainly don't want to be on the record
as against this thing
especially because they were getting
beaten up um
by john ossoff and remember warnock is
not being for 2000 dollar cash that was
which is a very politically unpopular
place to be
i mean the last numbers i saw were
something like 88 percent of americans
favor
some cash leap during the pandemic and
then like the popularity
varies based on the level but it's still
very very popular
and ossoff and warnock have received a
bump in the polls
for what they're worth they are polls
but the polls in georgia were relatively
accurate
um in the presidential election this
cycle it said it was gonna be a toss-up
lightly leaning democrat and that's
exactly what panned out
um and so they've gotten a bump recently
because we think
of their support and cash relief and it
seems to be a nonpartisan support
from the voters in georgia and
nationwide um
and then plus at the press cycle too
over and over on
this issue uh right before election day
right yeah mitch mcconnell literally at
some point said it's like well we need
to try and
help these senators um so that was one
of his
drives between authorizing the 600 cash
relief and then now
you know that mitch has essentially
signed off on the two of them coming out
for the two thousand dollars
and then he said like i'm gonna kill
this thing like you don't need to take
responsibility for killing it
uh like that that almost certainly has
gone on behind the scenes
um really in many ways the other
question is like marco rubio lindsey
graham the other republican senators who
are coming out being like let's do this
thing
you know that there are another dozen
republican senators who are thinking the
same thing and
and if again it came to a vote they
would just be like yeah let's do it
you know like some of the folks that i
think might be in that camp um i think
mitt romney's a possibility i think rob
portman of ohio is a possibility i think
there are other folks that
um that if they had a vote like they
would do it
um so so so the the politics of cash
relief and this is
a silver lining to this thing is that uh
cash is such a winning um
policy at this point that virtually
every democrat supports it and a lot of
republicans support it
um and among the american people that's
widely popular
uh and the socialism thing just isn't
working for people anymore like the the
like demonization of socialism because
you know
we've been bailing out the banks and
corporations to like such a high degree
where everyone's like looking like wait
a minute like what do you
want like like like what are you
complaining about it's like what
what happened to all these rich
corporations that are just getting money
hand over fist
all right guys we have a new sponsor and
i wanted to tell you about it because
it's
pretty cool if you're tired of using
some of these big name
household products that you don't really
know where they came from do you know if
they're good for the environment you
know
if they're good they're treating their
workers right you honestly don't and so
i want to talk to you about
something called public goods which is
essentially a one-stop shop for
sustainable high quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price so everything
from lily coffee to the shampoo
to toothpaste to pet food um it's your
new everything store but it's
thoughtfully designed for the conscious
consumer
i've tried a couple things they have a
surface cleaner that i think is pretty
great comes in a cool spray bottle
i have tried their olive oil recently
that i love i'm not the best cook but i
have been doing a little bit and they've
sent me some cool stuff
uh and their toothpaste actually pretty
awesome i've just replaced my crest
nonsense that i've just been grabbing
at you know the pharmacy when i go
um but they have literally it's it's
everything so the box that i've
i have of public goods um
goods um has been ranging from like food
to pet food to
uh cleaning materials rather than buying
from a bunch of single product brands
public goods member can buy all their
premium essentials
in one place in a beautiful website
beautiful aesthetic they look cool they
are good
um they're ethically sourced and they um
they obsessively develop their stuff
to be free of things that are unhealthy
or harmful additives that are still
common on drug and grocery store shelves
i'm very very committed to making their
products healthy and safe for humans
which is why we love them because
there's this commitment to
frankly humanity we've talked to public
goods and we've now just worked out as a
new sponsor here an exclusive deal just
for yank speaks podcasts listeners so we
receive 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase that's 15
off your first order no minimum purchase
so they're so confident that you'll love
their products and come back
again and again they're just going to
give you 15 bucks uh spend on your first
purchase pretty cool so go to
publicgoods.com
yang and use that or just use the code
yang at checkout
y n g so it's p u b l i
c g o o d s dot com forward slash yang
to receive 15 bucks 15 off your first
order check out public goods guys it's
pretty freaking cool
[Music]
i will confess to you zach that my sense
as to the odds of the democrats winning
have
changed uh my sense has changed over the
last number
of days and weeks so
um so you know you and i have spent a
lot of time in georgia
um uh knocking on doors and
having events uh for both candidates
and the energy has grown a lot over time
when we got started there was a lot of
pessimism
about democrats chances in georgia
and there were a few very very
reasonable reasons to be pessimistic
oh yeah so like i i certainly would talk
very optimistically but
if you looked at the landscape you would
say okay historically democrats have
fared
very poorly in runoffs in georgia
specifically
so so that that's not like a good uh a
good data point where the last time
there's a democratic runoff in georgia
just like you know it was
really really tight um in the actual
race and the person lost by like 10
points or something so so that that's
not a great
precedent um the other precedent is
actually buried in the
georgia vote totals themselves where joe
won
georgia by 12 000 votes very very thin
margin i mean millions of votes cast
uh and david perdue
uh had got more votes than john ossoff
by maybe
something like 60 or 70 000.
so there were at least some 70 80 000
georgians who showed up voted for joe
biden
and then voted for david perdue and not
john ossoff
um now that total number was you know
maybe less than a hundred thousand
georgians but still
like if you see november as like the
high water marks
then then you think okay um
the the odds are that the republican
wins because there were at least
some 80 to 100 000 georgians who
split their ticket and put their ticket
in a way that is not positive for
um for john ossoff so so those were some
of the data points
you had coming in another data point in
in the
warnock leffler race
uh reverend warnock got significantly
more votes than kelly lefler
in that race but there were something
like six significant candidates
and the republicans got significantly
more votes than the democrats
in in that race so if you look at
all of the data going in you were like
this is probably going to be a real
steep uphill climb for democrats in
georgia
and then that was compounded by the fact
that day one early on in the georgia
race the republicans piled in in a big
way
um where the the mitch mcconnell senate
super pac
bought tens of millions of dollars in
ads they sent a thousand operatives
like uh like they they are descended in
force in a way
um that seemed to supplement their
advantage
what's your prediction like i actually i
was with you or it's like i don't think
the dems would be able to pull this off
i thought it was likely that maybe split
look like kelly lefler is hateable
enough
um and kind of disgusting human who
sells her stocks before
uh when she finds out corona is
happening instead of uh warrington she
literally
gave it enough thought where she like
bought zoom she was like what's gonna
benefit
what like that's in this terrible time
yeah it was scummy though though david
perdue did something similar
uh they they both got dinged on insider
trading on
uh on the chronometer david perdue
didn't seem yeah like yeah doesn't seem
any better
but he's at least won an election before
i don't think i think she was appointed
right so
but my thought was i thought the dems
would split
um but it look it's looking like it may
have a better shot than i thought
i still think they split that's my
prediction but i've been wrong before um
i thought trump was gonna i'm i'm going
to push against
you on this zach where um so
i agree with you wholeheartedly that
david perdue has a much more real
connection with the people of georgia
than kelly lefler everyone knows the
purdue name it's very very famous
in georgia and david perdue won an
election in georgia so
you know he's been the senator
everyone's like yeah he's our senator
kelly lefler
like you said just got appointed uh last
year and everyone's like what
she's our senator or what
yeah uh and and driving around georgia
um i saw many more david perdue signs
and i saw kelly lefler signs like
david perdue actually has some real uh
affection
there in a way that kelly leflar does
not that said
i do not think it is feasible at all
that
hundreds of thousands of uh georgians
show up
and split the ticket like i do not think
that they're going to show up
and say david perdue yes but then i'm
going to
you know not vote in the other or vote
for reverend warnock like i just don't
see it
particularly given the inflammatory
nature of the messaging on the
republican side
where where there's just been like
essentially it's been fear fear fear
uh like that that's like their great
motivator for their voters right now
like vote for david perdue to save
america radical leftist john ossoff
radical leftist reverend warnock
um and even though john ossoff's a
white dude like there's just been a lot
of very racialized advertising
uh against both him and reverend warnock
reverend warnock in particular
some of the stuff they've done with the
reverend warnock advertising it's been
like completely out of context like he
had something where he was
saying hey we should like free people
who are in jail for marijuana which i
100 agree with and most people agree
with
and and they just played the clip being
like you know we have to like
you know like bring our kids home and
made it seem like you wanted just to
like
free everyone yeah so they take clips
out of his
his sermons um where he's all fired up
for like literally two seconds and
they're like listen i'm saying that like
i hate when people do that i hate that
um and most people get better about it
but political heads ads have not
well so so my point is that i just don't
see a lot of ticket splitting i think a
lot of people are just going to
show up and go dd or rr yeah so
even even though i do believe that david
perdue has a more authentic relationship
with voters and kelly leffler does i
think either they both win or they both
lose
so and who do you think is you think i
think the dems will pull this off
are you allowed to make prediction so
the data points that have come in that
have
made people more excited and positive
turnout and the early vote has been up
across the board
particularly in democratic leaning areas
100 000 georgians who did not vote in
november
have already voted in the runoff now
think about that for a second how the
heck
are you in georgia you you like missed
the presidential
which is like the highest stakes
presidential ever
and then now you've early voted uh in
this race
and i have a feeling that the bulk of
those hundred thousand people
are young people or disenfranchised
people that actually got activated by a
grassroots organization
during this time i think 22 000 for
example 17 year olds turned 18.
so so you know that might be a chunk of
the hundred thousand
um and for for people who don't know um
i co-founded
an organization called win both seats
that has funneled over two and a half
million dollars to 16
organizations that are activating voters
in georgia
primarily voters of color this like new
georgia project
and cares and
black male voters project and like a
series of others
so these organizations have been going
on the ground in buses just like showing
up and
activating voters and i think that's
where the new hundred thousand came from
um you know because it imag if you're a
republican in georgia
you voted for trump in november
like that that's like that's pretty
clear
so uh so those two data points are very
very positive for democrats
the early vote has come in strong there
are new voters
and the sole determinant of whether
republicans are going to win this is
whether they also get a turnout surge
on election day january 5th and as
you're listening
to this it's quite likely that donald
trump is rallying in georgia january 4th
um because he's actually showing up in
georgia to try and get out the vote
um if some proportion of
voters sit this one out on the
republican side then the democrats
win and that percentage does not need to
be enormous
like if let's say five to ten percent
of the folks who showed up in november
are like yeah i was there for trump and
it's not trump this time and
you know trump had some issues with the
process and
maybe this process isn't even fair maybe
i'm just going to sit this one out like
you know i have better things to do
like if that happens then democrats win
um
that's one reason why trump is coming
back in on the fourth the republican
party has been
begging him uh to try and activate his
voters in georgia
to try and get their turnout up so so
the signs are good for democrats in that
they've done their job
like they've gotten the their voters to
vote early
so i think that's a politician's answer
of saying you probably
advantage uh software not vantage
democrats in this one and you may be
right
um i think the republicans are a bit of
a catch-22 where it's like hey these
the election results were fake but hey
make sure you vote in this election
because we need it um like it's tough
it's tough to say both of those things
um that literally this is one thing that
i thought was like a sign of how
how weird it got in george on the
republican side
um the secretary of state of georgia is
republican
you know uh so like he's on their team
and then kelly lefler and david perdue
like were attacking him
and like calling him i think to resign
and then he was like i'm not resigning
um and they they were doing it because
they thought that would be like a sign
of loyalty to trump
um where uh and that's
i think one reason why uh lefleur and
perdue have come out for the two
thousand dollar checks
is they pretty much been like this is
the trump train and we're gonna get on
it for everything
um and if that includes trashing the
republican secretary of state
saying that the process wasn't fair then
let's do that too
um and so so so then turning around and
then saying it's like but we need you to
vote
uh then you're like wait didn't you just
like trash this this guy
this process um it's a strange narrative
uh and is it gonna be enough to keep a
few voters home
we will find out we'll find out who
knows
um oh man
look i mean look if we learn anything
from the november election is that
frankly most of the country if you live
in an
urban city in this nation you generally
speaking have no idea
what people around the rest of the world
particularly in red states
think what they're doing um and we find
out on election day
every time um in 2016 we're like oh
they're really upset
that's i mean because there's no media
there's no local media there's no way
for them to
for stories to kind of be lifted up so
um election day is
many ways the only way we find out
what's happening in rural america
which is dark but i think it's there's
some accuracy there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yank speaks is brought to you by helix
sleep guys i'm moving
into a new apartment in new york city
very very exciting
uh it's gonna be a little home office
situation
very very coveted friendly i'm pumped
and i had to
get rid of my old mattress because uh
i've outgrown it it's been a while so
i've gotten
a new mattress from helix sleep and it
comes in this beautiful box
extremely comfortable designed for me i
got to get all new sheets on it and
stuff too
getting your match is awesome and helix
sleep is
one of your best options out there so
basically how it works in typical yank
speaks fashion helix sleep does some
data gathering before you get your
mattress you take this quiz
it's like two minutes not even really
two minutes a few it's like you know
let's call it 90 seconds
um and it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the right mattress
for you
so if it's soft or firm or you like the
side you're a side sleeper or a back
sleeper
so when you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you get the mattress
it shows up at your doorstep
you can add on sheets and pillows or
whatever else you need for your bed
and it comes right to your door within
10 business days pretty cool they've
been awarded number one best overall
mattress pick
in 2020 by gq and wired magazine which
is pretty cool so these people
i want to be the guy that gets to vet
out mattresses you just sleep on them a
bunch of times but anyway i vetted out
this one and it's freaking great so here
you go
go to helixsleep.com yang take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress they'll give
you the best sleep
of your life and i mean that because
i've had some of the best sleep of my
life in this new mattress that i'm
moving in my new apartment with so right
now helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners that's helix
sleep.com
yang helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com get
up to 200 bucks off your order and two
free pillows
check it out
[Music]
i will say this two things one
this matters it matters a lot um so this
is literally the fate of the world
because
whether or not you you're republican or
democrat there are big problems this
country needs to solve
um and need to lead the world on call it
climate change call it ai called
automation that you've run on call it
handling coronavirus
and if we do not have a functioning if
we have a split congress
i think the odds i mean case in point
with cash really bill right now we're
not gonna get anything done we can't
even get that done
um and we have you know consensus on it
so
that's point one and point two um
i think this needs to be said and i'm
gonna rant is that
one of the things you did andrew and i
think this country owes you debt for
is normalizing cash relief now there's a
lot of talk on two thousand dollars this
man and they're not talking about andrew
yang in the press right now
and um i think
the fact that we're debating amounts
instead of debating whether this is a
crazy idea or not
is a lot to do with with why you ran um
you have normalized it the way that why
does bloodlight advertise it's not
because they have a new product or new
flavor or anything is that
they make it normal to order a bud light
they make it rational to bring bud light
to a party and no one questions it
and you normalize
cash relief you normalize universal
basic income so that these
clowns frankly can debate it all day
long but we don't have to debate whether
it's a crazy idea anymore because you
were the quote crazy one so
um this country owes you a debt for that
man whether they give you credit or not
and hopefully the people listening this
agree with me
and i don't know you're too humble to be
like oh it's all me but i will say that
that um
it wouldn't be happening i don't think
if you had run you know and you said
earlier i think a while i'd shudder to
think what solutions they'd be
presenting if we hadn't made cash relief
an option on the table does that make
sense
uh well i'm super indebted to you and
the yang gang everyone listening to this
uh because we did it you know if i'd run
for president
on universal basic income and never
made the stages never reached a level of
visibility and prominence where
then we could normalize it um
then we you and i wouldn't be having
this conversation i do think that
we have helped um make it acceptable for
everyone
just in the nick of time and it's here
to stay uh like this two thousand dollar
cash relief proposal is going to be
kicking around
until some version of it passes i
believe
because millions of americans are
looking up being like wait
like we haven't gotten [ __ ] since you
know april or whatever
that was like nine months ago and then
you're talking about 600 and like a lot
of people are like 600 like
uh you know and then and then they hear
like maybe 2 000
trump said 2000 like you know you can't
put this genie back in the bottle
like cash leaves here to stay until
the economy is prosperous again and this
economy has been prosperous for millions
of americans and decades
so you know so it's not going anywhere
and the pandemic has made everything so
much worse for tens of millions of
people
super grateful to you zach super
grateful to everyone who believed in us
uh i hope everyone's proud of what we've
done
thoughts um i certainly am proud
um and at this point i'm very happy to
not be the guy who
um like gets credit any time something
positive happens because that's actually
part of the normalization you know what
i mean
like if yeah
if you have these legislators or being
like yeah yeah yeah then it's like yeah
sure i mean take it it's yours
that's true that's a really good point
you've made this thing a thing and then
you've stepped away
the point where bernie can support it
mitt romney can support and the pope can
support it and it's
it's no one's thing anymore it's now
just its own
movement um and though
even though it is its own movement
though we're not above like calling
people and leaning on them or trying to
apply pressure oh yeah we have a right
leg we're like continuing to work
um but i'm i'm content to
work in a way that i think is effective
and i think that it's more effective if
people feel like they can own it
i agree there's not because we like look
when you worked for c worked for cnn
there's we have a
you know all the political reporters
nationally and locally we can call at
all time we are not calling them saying
give andrew more credit because we don't
think that's effective
um and i agree with that i think that's
been the right strategy it's working
well
um hopefully you get this passed geez um
and hopefully
frankly hopefully it impacts the georgia
senate race um
it already has a wild way i mean shoot
like that
like they but this is here to stay if
john and uh reverend warnock win
um it will be much much
more possible to get really positive
things out of government uh you know
it's why
uh you and i decided to fight it out in
georgia
um one of the things i i've i've said
probably in private but i'll say it
publicly whatever
is if you give washington an excuse not
to work
it will take it like that this is one
way to just get an excuse off the board
uh you know like right now that excuse
is mitch mcconnell it's like evan just
blame
everything on mitch which is not
inaccurate because mitch is being like a
total uh
[ __ ] obstructionist about a lot of
things uh
if if we can clear him out oh my gosh
then like everything becomes possible so
this podcast
is in many ways about the here and now
the immediate
it's not too late to help in georgia you
can still donate
to win both seats.org and money will
still flow to organizers
you can still bug your friends in
georgia to vote you can still
try and get something going even
down this last mile because the votes
are going to be counted through
tuesday night every vote's going to
count this thing is going to be close
and if we win it's going to be a new day
in dc
a new day in america and i'm really
really
hopeful uh getting to know these
candidates has made me even more pumped
for them
they would make tremendous u.s senators
and
uh their opponents are you know are in
the senate now and
not not many good things have been
happening amen
all right man it has been wild to watch
this thing shape out it is wilder that
the beginning of 2021 is going to start
with such a high stakes election that
we've had a lot of
uh active involvement in um
and i hope we hope i'm with you man
hoping of signs of good things to come
so
enjoy this clip it's it's not a normal
podcast i interviewed
the candidates for an event and these
are clips from that event
yeah um so you guys get another
candidate a bit and get to know andrews
here andrew's relationship with them too
so
enjoy it jon ossoff reverend warnock and
andrew let's go georgia
georgia dan five let's do it
and if you're new to your friends and
georgia we love you
georgia we're gonna love you even more
if you vote
blue we love you anyway georgia's
awesome anyway
but george i will say a lot of people in
the country will be very excited
no pressure georgia go save the world
love you guys enjoy the episode
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to this
incredible fundraiser
for jon ossoff and reverend warnock
welcome to both of you
you're going to save the country
yeah thank you so much andrew
wonderful to be here with you to save
the country no pressure at all
no pressure at all you guys are used to
it by now
so uh one of the arguments i get
uh because a lot of folks want to see dc
come together and they say hey we need
bipartisanship
uh and they're concerned that if we
elect both of you which obviously we
we're going to do i mean that's the
thing to do
the the concern they have is that
somehow
a balanced government is better than
having one party
in charge of everything now i i think
this is
frankly a dumb argument
but what is your response to that voter
i think a lot of us have been
feeling something in our hearts these
last few weeks that's a little
unfamiliar
given how this year in the last four
years have gone and it's that feeling is
hope
because trump is leaving there is
light at the end of the tunnel
in this pandemic and economic crisis
and zooming out bigger than that
the chance to author the next chapter
in our country's history and to do
things that
are so long overdue
expanding voting rights as a reverend
said passing a new civil rights act
criminal justice reform investing in
clean energy and infrastructure
to both rebuild our economy and create
good-paying jobs for working people and
also
to solve this environmental crisis to
finally make sure
andrew you do such a great job focusing
on this
because what has gone wrong in our
country that led us to this moment in
the first place
just because trump is defeated we can't
we have to recognize that these
deeper underlying problems persist and
leadership like his
only grows out of soil already poisoned
there are just far too many working
people in this country who can't make
ends meet
who can't afford housing health care
education
the basics who have no access
to dignified work that pays a living
wage so they can work just one job
who are denied equal justice under the
law those basic conditions of the
beloved community
that congressman lewis taught us about
and it's just not complicated how we get
there
we can see it we can see that future
it's tantalizing us we can enact
legislation
that solves these problems for ordinary
people
but only with the senate and so as we
think about the stakes
as we think about the stakes yes it is
empowering the health experts and
rushing
economic relief to people who are
suffering it's also bigger than that
it's also this opportunity
to progress america
on this journey that drew my mother to
this country as an immigrant when she
was 23 because she believed america was
on this journey
toward progress let's make the most of
this moment
win these two races so that we can
deliver for people who are hurting
and who have been hurting long before
this pandemic it genuinely does feel
like history has found the two of you
and put you in this position because so
much does rest on this race
and there could not be two better
individuals to represent
the democratic party and the hopes and
dreams of tens and millions
uh tens of millions of americans we need
to invest
in america one of the things that both
john and i agree on and we've been
talking about
is a historic investment in
infrastructure
which would include also green
infrastructure
so that we create jobs with a livable
wage for people in the short term
and position the american economy to
compete
in a global world uh in a in
amidst increasing globalization uh over
the long term
you know reverend and i were discussing
this recently and and how an
infrastructure plan can really unite the
people of the state because of the
economic opportunity that it represents
for communities urban suburban and rural
because
if done right it will mean equitable
access to economic opportunity for
marginalized communities because
it means that those nine rural hospitals
that have closed in ten years
can be replaced and more built it means
clinics can be built in underserved
areas it means
rural broadband which is the rural
electrification of our time
it means environmental remediation where
there's been contamination it means the
kinds of investments in clean energy
that mean we're not only building a
sustainable economy but also one
where georgia is the leading producer of
clean energy in the region
that is an initiative that can unite the
people of this state that can break down
partisan barriers
and what this moment represents in
georgia
again when you got a young jewish son of
an immigrant a white guy running
alongside a black pastor
the senior pastor at ebenezer baptist
church
and we present this vision of
opportunity
and health and justice for all people in
this state
what this is and what this will be is a
repudiation of the republican party's
southern strategy to divide
people in georgia and southern states
along racial and cultural lines so that
we fail to grasp
our shared interests we're presenting
to the people of georgia a vision that
stitches together
our interests and our values and reminds
us that
look we really all need the same things
out of life
and good government can make those
things real for working families who are
suffering here in georgia
and across the country and that's what
this is all about it's interesting i'm
here in georgia i have to say that
people of georgia clearly have a
stronger connection to david perdue than
they do kelly lefler
in large part because david perdue has
actually been elected you know
whereas kelly lefler was appointed and a
lot of people still don't know that much
about her
i have to say that it's a really
interesting dynamic um
we have to face facts that people are
going to show up and probably just vote
for
both of them or both of you so this
really is
a get out the vote effort in my mind if
all of the
voters who came out in november come
back then we're going to win
and that's what we're here today to to
make happen there are so many people
excited about you both
here tonight and you should know this
may be
posted in an environment where it gets
seen by the public so you know
tens hundreds of thousands of people so
for the folks who want to help you
aside from donating or even if they do
donate how can people help
we're not going to be able to match the
financial firepower of the national
republican party but we do need to be
able to hold our own so
deeply appreciate especially that
grassroots
financial support the five dollar ten
dollar fifteen dollar contribution
as folks can make them to support the
campaigns
and get involved by phone banking and by
reaching out to people that you know in
georgia
who may or may not be aware of this
upcoming election
make sure communicating where when and
how to vote and what the stakes are
and and it is a sort of
like a just a perfect distillation
of what's happening in georgia and in
american politics
these two races because you got in in
purdue and lefleur
the two most corrupt and out of touch
members of the us senate i mean when
when reverend warnock says
his opponent it's not just that her
family owns the new york stock exchange
is that they own the company that owns
the new york stock exchange
my opponent lives on a private island
behind like
three gates i mean you and both of them
both of them were too busy
looking after their own stock portfolios
to take care of the people they
represent both of them
opposed relief for ordinary people
while they were calling up their brokers
and trying to adjust their portfolios to
enrich themselves during a catastrophe
and while they were getting
classified briefings in washington
it's extraordinary but what we are doing
is delivering a message of hope
to the people here because this is all
about turnout
this is about electrifying mobilizing
unprecedented participation in our
democracy
because of a sense of hopeful
anticipation and inspiration about what
is possible when we win
and what this victory will mean in the
daily lives of ordinary people who are
hurting
who feel left out for whom the national
political narrative
is not relevant or resonant because they
rightly see politics
as this partisan corrupt circus that it
has become people who need
to be paid a living wage people who
fear that they may be bankrupted by a
bad diagnosis
people who do not trust that the justice
system will render justice
our task is to make sure that they know
that we are here to serve them and to
deliver
tangible relief
equity opportunity and justice in their
daily lives
are these men not phenomenal do they not
belong in the us senate
let us make that happen let's thank
the people that we are going to be
celebrating sending to the u.s senate
on january 5th john ossoff and reverend
warnock you all
you are phenomenal we have to make this
happen history is calling you have
answered the call now we have to do our
part
so if someone wants to help you guys
john where do they go what's the website
it's elect john elect jln.com and andrew
thank you and much love and looking
forward to seeing you in coming days
see you soon go get em reverend warnock
where do they go
the website is warnock
warnock4georgia.com
everything's spelled out warnock for
georgia spelled out.com
come and join us you don't have to come
to our state to volunteer you can do it
online digitally
and we're grateful for everybody out
there thank you so much
thank you reverend you are incredible if
you
were blown away as i was please do
make a contribution to their campaigns
phone bank
text bank tell your friends in georgia
let's
get everything behind them it's a sprint
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]